premier conseil des ministres première
polémique on en débat tout de suite avec
anne charlotte bezina bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes maître de conférences en droit
public claire chartier bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste auteur de le
violer nous enquête sur un fléau social
livre publié aux édition de
l'observatoire j'accueille également
jean daniel lévy bonsoir vous êtes
directeur délégué d'harris interactive
france et matthieu croissandeau il se
réalise ce politique bonsoir mathieu
bienvenue à vous aussi on va évidemment
parler de la sphère abad on attend là on
est en fin d'après midi une conférence
de presse du ministre des solidarités
mais j'aimerais d'abord quand même qu'on
parle de politique avec une émission
politique c'est pas édition de filières
et qu'on discute autour de ce que vous
inspire peut-être anne charrier de
bezina ce ce gouvernement bornes c'est
une équipe politique jusque là alors
c'est une équipe profondément politique
en effet c'est un peu le pompidou 3 de
2,66 c'est à dire qu'on est dans un
gouvernement de continuité on a il faut
dire un président qui de toute façon a
reconduit un mandat donc il n'y a pas de
véritable volonté disruptive de son côté
et on le sent il ya de la continuité il
ya aussi le retour du politique de
terrain finalement puisque en 2017 on
nous avait un petit peu parlé au
contraire de la société civile comme
étant la nouvelle compétences
ministérielles et au finish on se rend
compte que non la compétence ministériel
s'acquiert est plutôt dans le camp
politique alors politique aussi parce
qu'on l'a dit c'est le deuxième mandat
d' emmanuel macron et donc forcément
constitutionnellement son dernier et
donc on compose un petit peu cette
nouvelle renaissance centre un peu
élargie qui finalement est bien plus à
droite qu'à gauche puisque quand on
compte injustement dans les nouvelles
prisons en tout cas dans les ministres
de l'élargissement on est moins à gauche
qu'à droite quand même puisque notamment
tous les postes régaliens sont adroits
je pense notamment à bruno le maire à
gérald darmanin qui sont dans l'ordre
protocolaire les premiers à apparaître
et puis il faut lire voilà un ministre
de l'économie qui ne change pas ça veut
aussi dire qu'on va rester quand même
dans une profonde continuité alors c'est
pas nouveau on est fiers bérigaud ah on
a eu raymond barre qui sont restés
pendants plusieurs remaniements mais à
chaque fois donc avec cette idée
d'installer de la continuité donc pas de
pas de véritable surprise pas de
véritables grands noms non plus avec un
finalement un gouvernement qui sera le
gouvernement de son président est là on
est complètement dans la logique de la
vème république claire chartier votre
analyse qu'est ce que vous retenez de ce
premier premier conseil des ministres au
delà de la sphère abad on y viendra
après alors la thématique du pouvoir
d'achat évidemment qu'il n'y présente et
ça se comprend assez bien parce que
c'est difficile d'attaquer le
gouvernement sur cette thématique là
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour dire que face à l'inflation qui
galope il ya des mesures à prendre
il avait du pouvoir d'achat mais ce qui
m'a marqué dans la séquence que l'on
vient de vivre c'est que on a eu un
président qui a fait en fait durer le
suspense sur le gouvernement de sorte
que la campagne des législatives n'a pas
pu commencer ensuite il ya quand même eu
une surprise dans la nomination du
gouvernement est bien là quand même une
de taille c'est pape ndiaye
auquel effectivement on ne s'attendait
pas à la tête du ministère de
l'éducation et c'est un historien de
renom dont on connaît les positions il
parle d'un mot qui sonne qui ne serait
pas aussi massives que certains l'audi
d'un racisme éventuellement structurels
dans la police on qu'il était certain
absolument certain que l'extrême droite
allez hurler et en fait on a un peu
l'impression qu'ils emmanuel macron a
voulu dicter un peu la journal la
controverse c'est à dire qu'il a voulu
poser une bombe enfin il savait où ils
apposaient de façon à ce qu'ils sachent
exactement où aller exploser la bombe et
qu'est-ce qui se passe
une autre bombe qui arrive et ça elle
n'était pas prévue donc on a cette
thématique du pouvoir d'achat où
effectivement là à priori c'était aussi
le calme plat encore une fois parce que
personne ne veut aller les attaquer là
dessus même s'il ya quand même des
choses à dire on peut peut-être y
revenir après ce n'est pas à l'état lui
à lui tout seul quand même de faire les
chèques je pense que là alors ce sera le
thème de notre second débat donc on va
le
meilleur on y reviendra mais la bombe a
explosé un peu là où ils n'en
attendaient pas effectivement jean
daniel lévy je reviens sur l'histoire de
l'ordre protocolaire parce que ça peut
sembler anodin ça ne l'est pas ah non ça
ne l'est pas du tout vous l'avez indiqué
numéro deux du gouvernement monsieur
monsieur le maire numéro 3 monsieur
darmanin et il faut attendre la
cinquième position pour avoir la
première personne vers également en
charge au moins d'une partie des
thématiques écologiques et
environnementales donc à un signal qui a
été donné même si j'ai l'impression
qu'on a découvert sur le perron de
l'elysée que non seulement madame byrne
et les prémices n'a été pré ministre en
charge de la transition énergétique et
écologique alors que jusqu'à présent ce
n'est pas forcément des points qui était
accolé au premier ministre général le
1er mai uniquement prémices donc à
vraiment de les manuels macron là jusque
dans les attitudes et dans l'ordre
protocolaire et dans des messages qui
sont émis à l'égard de différentes
populations qui ont pu voter pour lui ou
qui peuvent le regarder d'un point de
vue plus ou moins positive la nomination
de pap ndiaye est également un message
implicite à l'égard de la gauche
notamment à l'égard de ceux qui se
déclarent proches de jean luc mélenchon
il sait que ça peut monter l'extrême
droite contre lui c'est effectivement la
nature des débats qui peuvent émerger et
au final on a un gouvernement qui est
surprenant et pas surprenant ce
surprenant parce qu'en fait on certains
ne peut-être pas à ce qu'ils aient
autant de personnes qui soit nommé dès
le premier temps nous avait parlé d'un
gouvernement resserré on a vu que ce
n'était pas le cas on a vu un ministre
de l'éducation nationale dont le nom
n'avait filtré que si je me trompe pas
10 ou 15 minutes avant l'annoncé mais
auparavant de personnes en avaient
entendu parler et dans un hammam et non
des personnalités qui sont facilités qui
était sans vouloir agir et les autres
qui étaient plus marquantes du précédent
quinquennat qui était à nouveau
renouveler souvent au même pas soit avec
des postes de responsabilité la
thématique en gros des manuels macron
c'était 50 plus dans le cas de sa
campagne électorale et là à travers le
premier gouvernement piloté par
elisabeth bornes ou la sensiblement
effectivement l'idée qui aura
globalement une continuité en tout cas
sur les points qui apparaissent comme
l'inter est essentielle au président la
réplique on reviendra un peu plus tard
en dise on consacrera un chapitre entier
à la nomination de de pap ndiaye parce
qu'effectivement elle et elle est forte
en symboles mais je voudrais quand même
qu'on consacre un peu de temps sur la
planification écologique avec ce trio
100% féminin algérienne bezina vous en
pensez quoi alors c'est en tout cas une
première sous la vème république qu'on
est un premier ministre attirer en effet
on a première ministre virgule chargé 2
alors ça c'est tout à fait inédit je
pense aussi qu'il ya une raison
technique à cela c'est que tout ce qui
relève de l'écologie étant donné que
surtout il ya plusieurs chantiers c'est
à dire qui aura des chantiers
immobiliers etc eh bien ce sera dans le
giron de l'intergouvernemental et en
france et le secrétariat général du goût
donc c'est matignon qui doit s'occuper
de tout ce qui est interdit au
gouvernement tu as donc je sais je pense
que c'est notamment pour ça que la
première mais cette nouvelle
qualification pour notamment chapeauté
tout cela après c'est vrai qu'on a deux
ministre de l'environnement alors ça
peut se discuter parce que auparavant
nous avait vendu un peu j'ai envie de
dire l'idée que le ministère de
l'écologie notamment confié avec un
ministère d'état je pense notamment à
ségolène royal eh bien allez avoir son
indépendance est allée du coup pouvoir
incarner un petit peu plus l'écologie
politique alors qu'ici on a finalement
des ministres placée sous l'autorité du
premier ministre qui ne sont plus
vraiment indépendante qu'est ce que ça
changerait la gouvernance est ce que ça
va colorer un peu différemment
l'écologie politique c'est vraiment des
questions intéressantes à se poser
mathieu c'est juste une demi surprise
quand même parce que monet macron avait
abordé cette question là lors de son
meeting à marseille vous souvenez
d'entre deux tours vous l'avez parler de
ce futur où cette future premier
ministre qui serait encadrée de ses deux
ministres est là pour le coup il a tenu
parole il n'y a pas vraiment de surprise
on le fait qu'il est qu'il ait fait ce
qu'il avait dit qu'on en fait si on
regarde un peu les choses et une
ministre de l'écologie à qui on donne
quand même une tout un tout a volé
cohésion des territoires qui est a
minima et une mise de l'énergie qu'on
appelle de la transition énergétique
mais qui minent mise de l'énergie ce cas
c'est nouveau c'est que l'énergique a
longtemps était dans le giron de la
sphère économique et de bercy la se voit
rattacher directement dans la dans la
sphère plus écolo sous l'autorité
directe de la de la première miss qui
est chargé chargé sa la fouine
responsabilités qui lui incombent et ce
en même temps une mission que prédisant
lui donne cdc dans les deux sens dans
lequel elle chapeaute en même temps elle
doit faire le job et c'est vrai que pour
la symbolique c'était important parce
que c'est un dossier on sait bien qui
est majeur aujourd'hui danse pour les
jeunes générations mais pas que et puis
c'est vrai que pour la transversalité du
boulot c'est-à-dire pour le caractère
intergouvernemental de cette question là
qui transforme tout une partie des
ministères c'est la première fois en
france que peut-être tous les leviers
d'action seront là directement à
maintenir parce que l'urgence rappelé
par le giec les scientifiques du g20 ces
trois ans et elle nous concerne tous pas
seulement les jeunes générations est
bien d'accord mathieu ce qu'est ce qui
est intéressant c'est peut-être la
notion transversalité parce que
justement c'est moi
un gros ministère politique qui essaye
de poser c'est la transversalité des
enjeux de l'écologie puis aussi dans ce
triumvirat de féminin l'identification
quand même à des domaines majeurs en
fait c'est quand même un message envoyé
à l'opinion parce que à la fois la
cohésion des territoires on le sait
c'est déterminant dans la transition
écologique on l'a bien vu avec les gilet
jaune et on ne cesse de le voir donc
c'est un volet majeur il faut qu'on
associe les gens et notamment ces
populations à la transformation si non
nous n'y arriverons pas et l'énergie
c'est tout aussi majeur donc je pense
que c'était aussi une façon d'identifier
très clairement au regard de l'opinion
publique l'action qui allait être menée
enfin on l'espère en tout cas la volonté
de le faire et puis aussi l' expertise
parce que ce sont des femmes qui
effectivement ont démontré des vraies
compétences au ministère dans lesquels
étaient précédemment donc de ce point de
vue là aussi je pense que tout est fait
pour indiquer à la fois la volonté et
rassurer aussi l'opinion publique sur la
démarche est aussi lallaoui la
philosophie en fait qui va être adoptée
dans la façon d'appréhender ce problème
écologique jean daniel lévy s'est alors
c'est tout c'est un de vos confrères aux
concurrences et ipsos pour le cevipof
l'opinion des français à l'égard de la
nomination d'elizabeth bornes
l'indifférence qui domine on cite le
match est serré mais 38 % se disent
indifférents 34 % se disent satisfaits
28 % se disent mécontents est ce que
c'est parce qu'il ya pire le
l'indifférence finalement que c'est ce
qu'a de pierce existe souvent sous la
vème république quand vous regardez les
premiers ministres c'est pas forcément
la tante magistral qui pestait or
évidemment permet de deux cohabitations
et si vous êtes encore plus renforcé
avec la présence d' emmanuel macron
parce qu'en fait emmanuel macron aux
yeux des français il est président de
l'apli clé près ministre il est garde
des sceaux et les ministres des affaires
étrangères donc en fait il occupe
quasiment toutes les fonctions et ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est que on a
quand même vécu cette pub je vais d de
flottement en tout cas sans démission de
jean castex ne savait qui partait avec
l'arrivée d'elisabeth bornes et à un
gouvernement qui a mis du temps à être
présentés est ce que les français ont
été profondément déstabilisé un patient
critique ou en disant il nous faut
toucher son gouvernement on n'était pas
du tout dans cette situation là il ya
plutôt la perception à tort ou à raison
qu'on est face à une pouvoir politique
est clairement incarnée par emma coup
avec une impulsion qui vient clairement
de sa part et que les autres acteurs
sont des acteurs qui sont plutôt en
charge de l'exécution globalement de ce
qui a été décidé impulser de la part du
président de la république et ce qui est
assez frappant c'est que on n'a pas
vraiment le sentiment qu'il ya des
sensibilités très marquée au sein du
gouvernement par le passé ça existait
des personnes qui a coûté une fibre
sociale de tout des fibres libéral
d'autres plutôt des fibres
d'intervention et à terme là ça existe
indéniablement montre en tout cas à
aucun moment ça a été mis en avant comme
étant des éléments constitutifs de ce
compte de ce que sont les personnalités
qui sont présentes au sein du
gouvernement elle arrive pour mettre en
oeuvre la politique qui a été décidé de
la part d' emmanuel macron et pas
forcément en fonction de leurs
convictions initial profonde qui
donnerait à voir de ce que pourrait être
une politique incarnée par une
personnalité père particulière pierre
chartier la première ministre s'est on a
souvent dit on l'a dit plusieurs fois
ici voilà le technicienne bosseuse
efficacité et finalement c'est cette
capacité à réformer sur laquelle on va
peut-être
l'évaluer puisqu'on met en avant
justement sa connaissance des dossiers
sa capacité à voile à emporter peut-être
par sa poigne les décisions tout ça ça
va être ça fait tâche d une certaine
façon elle a fait ses preuves
effectivement par le passé aussi la sncf
s'était quand même pas mince à réformer
on a connu des fortes résistances sur ce
dossier là auparavant elle a quand même
réussi à emporter la faire ils
assureront chômage aussi donc elle est
connue pour ça elle est connue pour
aussi ses grands talents de négociatrice
donc elle ne lâchera rien ça c'est
certain et effectivement dans un
contexte dans un gouvernement très
technique en fait peut-être pas
technocratique parce que c'est un mot
péjoratif mais effectivement qui
apparaît comme très technique c'est la
technicienne en chef donc on peut se
dire que effectivement de ce côté là
elle ne va rien lâcher en revanche c'est
l'issue quand même des législatives qui
sera déterminante parce que réformer
c'est bien joli la volonté si on peut la
voir mais si on n'a pas les troupes pour
réformer on est quand même assez démunis
donc le résultat est évidemment
essentiel et puis aussi tout le contexte
parce qu'on sait très bien que la
société française est dans un état quand
même de tension intense et puis il ya
une sorte de credo enfin une sorte
d'idée qui s'est installée que nous
allions vrai très mal je trouve que là
ça a gagné ça fait c'est pas nouveau
chez nous en france mais là ça a pris
des proportions absolument abyssal à tel
point que on ne voit même pas ce qui
fonctionne chez nous donc nous sommes
vraiment inscrit dans une oeuvre dans
une dans l'idée que la france s'enfonce
donc réformer dans ce contexte là avec
une opposition qui va être quand même
probablement assez féroce puisque la
majorité puisque emmanuel un conte n'est
pas du tout sûr enfin c'est pas du souci
évident que finalement
ça me semble difficile donc c'est plus
le contexte extérieur qui va peser à mon
sens que la personnalité elle-même
d'elisabeth bande pas de photo de
famille mathieu c'est la météo sans
doute sans doute météo pauline est pas
beau à paris à la météo aux havrais ont
élevé des eaux politique c'est vrai que
ce conseil des ministres ce premier
conseil des ministres qui doit marquer
les premiers pas du gouvernement s'est
fait quand même dans une atmosphère
largement plombé par le scandale la fête
soit belle affaire abah de rennes 1 et
par mediapart il s'est alors vent de
rupture de la tradition d'ailleurs il me
semble mais sans vouloir avancer mais
c'est plus ou moins la première fois
qu'un conseil des ministres est pas
émaillée de cette photo de famille qui
est vraiment traditionnelle sur le
perron donc le bon c'est mauvais signe
ouais météo alors justement le le cas
damien abad peut-il tenir face à ces
accusations de violence sexuelle tiens
je vous propose de réaction politique
très contrastées pour commencer celle de
claire darcos sénatrice l air de
l'essonne vice président de la
délégation des droits des femmes au
sénat et puis sandrine rousseau ancienne
candidate aux primaires d'europe
écologie les verts on les écoute notre
justice en france fait que on a
presentation d'innocence tant que vous
n'êtes pas ni mis en examen
ni condamnés dans ce cas précis je vous
dis j'étais très ému par son sens comme
unité clé plutôt
plutôt la tendance à le croire lui la
question n'est pas sa démission à lui
mais le fait qu'il soit démis de ses
fonctions par principe de précaution il
ya deux il y a deux témoignages de
femmes qui ne se connaissent pas qui
sont concordants qui relate des faits
qui sont assez similaires et par
ailleurs manifestement chez les
républicains il y avait il à vue il
était précédé d'une réputation que
plusieurs personnes ont confirmé
plusieurs cadres des républicains ont
confirmé donc il ya un principe de
précaution qui fait qu'il faut protéger
et il faut envoyer un message assez fort
aux femmes que leurs paroles comptes
clairs chartier je rappelle que vous
avez enquêté sur ce fléau social qu'est
le viol livre publié aux édition de
l'observatoire comment vous analysé
cette affaire alors je pense qu'elle a
deux jolies et il me semble que
elisabeth bande n'a répondu qu'à un des
deux volets en fait le premier c'est
cette plainte cette première plainte qui
a été déposée donc il ya une dizaine
d'années qui a été classée sans suite
parce que l'infraction n'était pas
caractérisée est en effet effectivement
on ne peut pas mettre en examen
quelqu'un si on n'a pas les éléments
pour le faire et c'est toute la
difficulté de ces affaires là c'est que
les infractions sont très difficile à
caractériser parce que les éléments sont
durs à rassembler mais ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est pas parce que cette
plainte a été classée sans suite que les
faits n'ont pas lieu en fait ce n'est
pas ce que dit le classement le
classement dis simplement qu'on ne peut
pas on peut pas mettre en examen donc
demeure une sorte de doute c'est
vraiment caractéristique de ces dossiers
or on est dans un contexte politique on
est dans un contexte où la défiance
envers le politique non seulement ne
reflue pas mais s'accentue dans un
gouvernement où le ministre de
l'intérieur a eu affaire à la justice et
dont la faire pour viol a pas encore été
jugé donc y'a quand même tout un
contexte qui insiste à une si ce n'est
enfin au moins une forme de vigilance à
l'égard de ce genre de deux fait donc ce
qui est quand même assez étonnant c'est
qu'il n'ait pas été regardé s'il voulait
en fait désigné comme ministre un
personnage qui dans son cv à cette ombre
qui obscurcit l'ensemble bon c'est quand
même assez étonnant que je n'ai pas eu
de finalement de réflexion autour de ça
et le deuxième volet là à mon avis
renvoie aux côtés au sol côté que je
vois négatif au formidable mouvement qui
ai mis tout c'est effectivement le
risque du tribunal populaire ça il
existe aussi parce que effectivement de
plus en plus de gens
finalement considère que un témoignage
ça vous vérité objective et qui à la
limite c'est même pas la peine de
déposer plainte dès l'instant où
quelqu'un qui se présente comme victime
et peut-être létale encore une fois ce
n'est pas là ce que je discute mais dès
l'instant où il ya un témoignage et que
ça suscite un émoi dans l'opinion
publique eh bien les faits sont avérés
mois effectivement je pense que là nous
sommes sur une pente qui est assez
dangereuse parce qu' aucun pays ne peut
se dire démocratique si il ne dispose
pas d'un système juridique qui protège
le droit des victimes et les droits de
la défense et là nous sommes en train
parce que les faits parce qu' il était
temps de se rendre compte de l'ampleur
de ce phénomène qu'on se construit et va
lever complètement moi j'ai finalement
j'ai découvert qu'on pouvait au moins
dire qu'il y avait cent mille cas par an
de viol ce qui est énorme et encore
certainement il y en a d'autres donc il
était complètement sous évalué donc on a
l'impression qu'il ya une série d'une
cascade d'affaires en politique
simplement parce que on est en train de
mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène et voilà
s'il n'y a pas du tout de tyrannie n'y a
pas eu de cession sait simplement qu'il
existe mais prenons garde quand même
essayons vraiment de discerner on va
garder ce sens de la mesure et se soit
dernier hamad s'est exprimé devant la
presse si le jourdain vous avez écouté
cette conférence de presse 2
abad on va l'écouter tout de suite
damien abad
je conteste les accusations à mon
encontre avec la plus grande des
fermetés toutes les relations sexuelles
que j'ai pu avoir dans ma vie ont
toujours été mutuellement consenti ces
accusations m'inflige comme à mon
entourage une blessure profonde j'ai
toujours évité de mettre mon handicap en
avant j'étais contraint malheureusement
de le faire aujourd'hui pour me défendre
et même de dévoiler mon intimité en
détail en expliquant que les faits qui
mettait imputé était matériellement
impossible
ce sont ici et ma dignité et mon
intégrité qui s'en trouve atteinte je le
répète avec fermeté je n'ai jamais violé
une seule femme de ma vie vous
comprendrez qu aborder ces sujets
publiquement est extrêmement douloureux
pour moi désormais je me consacre à ma
mission de ministre un ministre qui
souhaite être sur le terrain au plus
près de la vie quotidienne des français
garder les pieds sur terre et je suis
aussi pleinement engagé dans ma campagne
législative comme candidat dans la 5e
circonscription de l'ain je vous
remercie
voilà pour cette déclaration c'était il
ya quelques minutes de damien abad six
jours d'un qu'est ce qui lui est
reproché si on reprend le point de
départ de très graves accusations de
viol damien abad faut le rappeler un
c'est l'ancien président du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale
c'est le nouveau ministre des
solidarités de l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées c'est la seule grosse prise
de guerre à droite du nouveau
gouvernement à maquereau ça c'est pour
le contexte politique est il important
les faits présumés on va les voir deux
femmes accusent damien abad de viol pour
la première on est en 2010 et se serait
réveillée dans un hôtel en sous
vêtements aux côtés de damien abad elle
ne se souvient de rien à part avoir bu
la veille et bien une coupe de champagne
pour la seconde accusation en est un an
après on est en 2011 à victime présumée
avait 22 ans était une militante
centriste elle raconte qu'elle a été
draguée avec insistance qu'elle a
finalement accepté d'avoir une relation
sexuelle en accession qu'elle a tenté
d'interrompre mais sans succès damien
banon viens de l'entendre ni les faits
il l'avait déjà fait dans un munich est
trouvé il nie fermement ces accusations
il a entendu la fait aussi dans ce
communiqué qu'on va voir je conteste
avoir exercé quelque forme de contrainte
que ce soit sur aucune femme je conteste
enfin tout abus de pouvoir lié aux
fonctions que j'ai occupées je suis
contraint aujourd'hui de préciser que
dans ma situation l'acte sexuel ne peut
survenir qu'avec l'assistance et la
bienveillance de ma partenaire fin de
citation rappelons que damien abad est
atteint d'une maladie congénitale rare
qu'ils empêchent de bouger de se mouvoir
normalement jusqu'à sa nomination au
gouvernement c'était le seul
parlementaire en situation de handicap
thomas alors que dit la justice jusqu'à
présent de ses affaires deux classements
sans suite par le parquet pour la
deuxième affaire celle de 2011 en
revanche l'autre femme celle qui s'est
réveillée sans se souvenir de comment
elle s'était endormie est bien décidé
récemment de s'adresser à l'observatoire
des violences sexistes et sexuelles
c'est un observatoire créé dans la
foulée du mouvement mis tout son but
faire la lumière sur les agissements des
responsables politiques en matière de
violences sexuelles
nous on a été informés par une des
victimes par un courrier
on a immédiatement transmis ce courrier
à trois personnes chez arm qui sont
christophe castaner bérengère couillard
et un stanislas guérini et on a
transféré aussi ce courrier à monsieur
aurélien pradié clr ils disent tous
qu'ils n'ont pas pu consulter leurs
mails qui n'ont pas du lait mais nous on
a quand même un petit problème par
rapport à ça quand même c'est que on
fait déjà un travail qui normalement ne
devrait pas être de notre ressort ça
devrait être aux partis politiques de
considérer les violences sexistes et
sexuelles comme des faits graves et donc
de faire eux-mêmes ce travail de
s'assurer de la probité de leurs
candidats voilà noter que le signalement
a également été transmis au procureur de
la république qui lui a bien accuser
réception du message comment
gouvernement réagit-il à cette affaire
présomption d'innocence aucune raison
pour le moment de démettre damien abad
de ses fonctions ce sera à la justice de
trancher écouter
tolérance zéro pour les délinquants
sexuels
l'enjeu c'est ici
l'établissement de la vérité
et l'établissement de la vérité c'est à
la justice de le faire
ça n'est pas à moi
et je crois que ça n'est pas non plus à
vous voilà pour la position du
gouvernement je parle sous votre
contrôle madame bezina mais il existe
une règle non écrite en matière
d'affaires les ministres mis en examen
sous la vème république dans une affaire
doivent démissionner affaire à suivre
merci beaucoup style justement de
charlotte bezina c'était c'était à
l'époque de films du gouvernement
balladur si je me souviens c'est une
jurisprudence est encore le terme est
très mal choisi ce que la jurisprudence
est créée par le juge mais voilà nos
manuels de droit concessionnels adore
parler de la jurisprudence balladur
bérégovoy qui en réalité remonte bien
avant puisque le premier ministre
démissionnaire et en 72 soula de son
premier ministre chaban delmas mais
pourquoi balladur bérégovoy parce que
elle remonte notamment à cette période
un peu trouble des affaires tapie et
c'est pour ça qu'on a on l'a on l'a
ressorti à ce moment là et qu elle a été
modernisée à ce moment là qu'est ce
qu'elle signifie cette coutume cette
pratique c'est qu'au stade de la mise en
examen et c'est important de s'arrêter à
ce moment là parce que la mise en examen
en procédure pénale c'est le moment des
indices graves et concordants sont
réunis pour caractériser une infraction
donc ont considéré sous la vème
république que le moment de la mise en
examen est un enterrement ou en quelque
sorte la courtoisie politiques faisaient
que le ministre notamment parce qu'il
est nommé par le premier ministre et le
président est bien en espèce de
parallélisme des formes et bien c'était
à lui de présenter sa démission pour ne
pas atteindre j'ai envie de dire par
effet de tache d'huile et bien la
légitimité du gouvernent en tant que tel
néanmoins cette jurisprudence elle est
vraiment à géométrie variable parce que
par exemple sous le premier ministre
était françois fillon elle a quasiment
pas été appliquée puisqu'on à claude
guéant et christine lagarde qui sont
maintenus en poste alors que christine
lagarde par exemple à une affaire cour
de justice de la république donc en
qualité de ministre et pourtant on
choisit la solidarité et donc on ne se
voit là on n'applique pas et premier
gouvernement emmanuel macron alors il ya
à la fois une extrême prudence avec les
élus modem avant la mise en examen qui
décide finalement d'être enfin par une
espèce de commandes accords qui sont
démis du gouvernement qui le décide et c
est pourtant gérald darmanin on peut
même encore pensé récemment à eric
dupond moretti qui est justement encore
en contentieux avec la cour de justice
de la république où on ne l'appliquent
pas donc comme c'est une coutume et que
rien n'est imposé dans les textes et
bien on voit bien que c'est
l'opportunité politique c c'est
intéressant parce qu'on est un peu à la
frontière entre la légalité et la
légitimité finalement parce que
légalement il ya une responsabilité
politique du ministre en tant que
ministre sinon pénalement article 6 de
notre déclaration il est évidemment un
citoyen comme les autres donc il doit
être jugé mais jusqu'où politiquement
même alors que l'affairé n'est pas
encore jugée et bien cette j'ai envie de
dire cette atteinte à l'honneur et
suffisante pour quitter un gouvernement
ou pas c'est une grande question de
curseur que la vème république n'a
encore parisot lui apparemment jean
daniel lévy ont parlé tribunal populaire
comment alors c'est trop tôt cette
affaire mais comment l'opinion publique
réagit dans ces affaires-là d'une
je sais pas si c'est modélisable
d'ailleurs déjà c'est la première fois
qu'on se retrouve dans une situation à
ce niveau là on peut pas considérer que
chaque situation souvent entièrement
transposable mais en fait on se rappelle
qu'à l'époque de gérald darmanin il y
avait eu également des interrogations et
des doutes et je vous rejoins
entièrement c'est à dire que le fait que
la justice soit passé ou ne soit pas
passé le fait qu'ils aient un
signalement des interrogations des
témoignages quelle que soit la défense
fait qu' il ya un peu l'adage populaire
il n'y a pas de fumée sans feu qui
ressort en se disant que de toute façon
ça atteinte à l'image de gérald darmanin
en tant que ministre l'intérieur ne
s'est jamais amélioré au cours de
l'ensemble de cette séquence il y avait
même quand vous regardiez en matière de
genre selon les personnes qui était
interrogé 1 est déficit d'approbation de
la part des femmes probablement lynch
pas beaucoup de mal à s'affirmer mes
problèmes liés à justement ce soupçon et
qui pouvaient exister à l'égard de
gérald darmanin peut-être que la la la
la pression risque d'être encore plus
importante cette fois ci d'un point de
vue d'opinion parce que on n'a pas une
histoire qui est très marquée de la part
de monsieur abad précédemment fait en
tout cas qui n'est pas identifié de
manière très marquée d'un point de vue
des français et puis également que
peut-être la politique est parfois fait
comme ça ses anciens amis proches des
républicains vont pas forcément venir
l'aider ou l'appuyer et donc il ne va
pas forcément y avoir ce phénomène de
corps qui a pu exister par le passé et
plutôt en fait des des formes de
critiques ou d'absence de soutien damien
abad qui a pris la parole également en
répondant à nos confrères du figaro il
affirme dans ce dans cette interview
claire chartier les élections
législatives seront les juges de paix
c'est drôle de
formule est finalement mais on est on
est finalement dans la logique de ce
tribunal populaire dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure il dit bouba c'est ça de
toute façon la justice est lui même je
suis innocent finalement puisque c'est
le tribunal populaire les espions
jugeront quoi lui même en fait d'un
certain veut dire que ça tombe enfin
c'est tout à fait curieux je trouve que
cette fois ce n'était pas à lui de dire
cela c'est effectivement pas aux
citoyens aux électeurs de trancher ce
genre d'affaires enfin c'est vraiment
complètement digne et enfin le rôle de
la justice et son action donc je trouve
ça aberrant totalement jeu vraiment je
m'étonne et je pense qu'il va voir quand
même du mal effectivement à rester parce
que là on est dans une séquence où quand
même les épisodes se succèdent il n'ya
pas longtemps on avait quand nicolas
hulot et alors là on vraiment l'ampleur
du désastre tout le monde le connaît
donc je pense que là il ya un effet
d'accumulation et encore une fois il ya
un manque de vigilance politique qui est
tout à fait ostentatoire vient c'est
quand même incompréhensible que sans
même parler des alertes qui ont
effectivement pu se perdre dans les
mails j'en sais rien les messageries les
boîtes dont c'est compliqué mais enfin
quand même eu l air savait déjà eu de
leur côté ils savaient bien qu'ils
avaient ce problème puisque christian
jacob a reconnu qu'il en avait parlé en
2017 je crois julien aubert aussi donc
c'était quand même connu cette histoire
dans le milieu politique quand on veut
nommer quelqu'un ministre enfin quand
même on se doit d'être au courant de ce
genre d'épisode juridique donc je ne
comprends pas et là à mon sens il ya un
mot qui souvent employés dans les
commentaires il ya une faute et là à mon
sens effectivement il ya une faute
politique est commise donc après on va
voir ce qu'ils vont faire mais je pense
que non seulement c'est une faute et en
plus je trouve qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose de très dérangeant vous
rappeliez gérald darmanin mais là il ya
vraiment un sous-seing là je trouve un
soupçon d' hypocrisie de la part du
gouvernement macron qui nous dit les
violences faites aux femmes on est très
attentif à cela vraiment on veut faire
avancer les choses c'est ce qu'on entend
d'ailleurs pardon vous interrompre mes
dents dans l'extrait qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure de la l'intervention d'olivier à
grégoire la nouvelle porte oui c'est bon
pied la côte et on y va à fond on est
vraiment déterminée et de l'autre se
comporter de cette manière il ya quand
même la haye at us et on regarde
l'opinion publique qui ne connaît pas
toutes les circonvolutions ils étaient
toutes les arcanes juridiques mais il ya
un hiatus qui est quand même
difficilement soluble de même et donc
s'allier à dire que de deux principes la
présomption d'innocence avait forcément
balayé aujourd'hui alors ces jeux j'y
reviens je voulais rajouter un mot vous
pariez d'effet boule de neige mais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu aussi très récemment je
me souviens plus du nom de l'élu qui a
été mise en cause pour violences
alger 11 journées pause voilà qui est on
à la fraise de stanislavski hemani qui
dit finalement je ne le crois pas
capable de ça et c deja donc cet homme
c'est un honnête homme et donc j'ai
envie de dire la légalité est ici dans
un espèce d'angle mort mais il ya
surtout une question discours à tenir
aussi qu'il a n'a pas été vraiment
forcément vigilant et malheureusement
comme vous lisiez ce alors je dis
malheureusement je dis malheureusement
pour la parole des femmes pour toutes
ces questions de société qui se posent
mais on a ce principe de présomption
d'innocence qui est cardinal sur lequel
pour moi on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
renier comme vous le disiez dans une
démocratie il faut aussi que il y a un
temps de la justice il faut que y est un
secret de l'instruction il faut qu'il y
ait une contradiction des preuves et
tous ces éléments pénaux en fait on est
on les oublie alone justement de ce
qu'on peut appeler l'acte de réputation
et est-ce qu'on va rentrer dans cette
démocratie du soupçon est ce qu on y est
en plein est ce qu'on veut la rendre
légitime c'est quand même des questions
qu'il faudra se poser pour les
générations qui laissera donc on épluche
les comptes épargne de tous les
candidats à travers la hot wheels la
haute autorité de la transparence
biblique et que d'une certaine façon
on screen pas comme des américains le
passé tout le mandat c'est la sphère est
très compliqué parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu 2 2 plaindre et ont été
classées sans suite mais on est dans un
moment politique pour les mêmes faits
pour les même faits des accusations de
première la première fois parce qu'elle
n'a pas souhaité elle-même donné suite
et puis la seconde fois parce que ça n'a
pas permis de caractériser l'infraction
comme le rappelait faire chartier on est
dans un moment politique particulier
parce que la question des violences
faites aux femmes parce que la question
de la place de la femme dans la société
en général revêt aujourd'hui et il faut
s'en féliciter un aspect beaucoup plus
fondamentale primordial prioritaires
essentiel que ça ne l'a été depuis des
années il faut reconnaître aussi que
toutes ces affaires sort beaucoup été
mis sous le tapis par le passé parce que
on passe l'épongé ou parce que ce sont
des choses dont on ne parlait pas donc
un problème du point de vue juridique et
je vous rejoins tout à fait la
présomption d'innocence et c'est
cardinal pour nous d'un point de vue
politique c'est sûr que le message est
entièrement beau lui parce qu'on est en
plus dans un timing particulier c'est la
première fois que ce gouvernement enfin
c'est le premier jour de l'action de ce
gouvernement il ya des élections
législatives dans trois semaines donc on
se dit est ce que le risque politique de
nommer damien abad a été bien
appréhendée est ce que le bon coup
politique entre guillemets qui était
allé voler une des têtes
une des têtes de gondole de des
républicains pour faire un débauchage de
plus en demande dans un gouvernement en
valait la chandelle est ce que ça a été
arbitré ou est-ce que personne n'était
au courant dans les deux cas c'est une
faute avait demandé de castéra j'ai du
mal à comprendre qu'un françois de rugy
n'ai démissionné pour toi ou marais que
damien abattu juste rester en poste
pendant encore de longues semaines ça va
durer plus longtemps qu à voir oui mais
bon c'est sympa et et savait pas été
assez immédiat mais ce qui est certain
c'est que vous parlez tous de la justice
mais en fait il ya un soupçon à l'égard
de la justice quand vous interrogez les
français sur le fait que celle ci donne
et rentre véritablement et des décisions
qui soient objectivement juste avec une
interrogation sur la puissance que
pourraient avoir certains qui ferait que
au final de toute façon il s'en sortira
toujours parce que il ya un soupçon de
corruption qui parlent pas forcément
uniquement financières mais également de
collusion entre les élites et qui dut
manière de l'autre vont être amenés à
céder et là on fait ou la défaillance
est un point de vue d'opinion est la
plus marquée si la part de la jeunesse
quand vous interrogez aujourd'hui en
fait les jeunes générations et une
défiance à l'égard de la justice qui
manifestent une confiance à l'égard de
la parole des victimes qui fait
quasiment neuf deux décisions et donc
qui dans ce contexte là fait qu'on va
même plus forcément entendre en fait
ceux qui vont être amenés à se défendre
comme damien abad mais beaucoup plus en
fait considéré qu'à partir du moment où
certains osent prendre la parole
cette prise de risque de leur part
apparaît comme étant suffisamment
importante pour lui laissant entendre
que celle-ci est la vérité allez on
ouvre un dernier chapitre dans ce débat
autour de la nomination de pap ndiaye
comme ministre de l'éducation nationale
on l'a un peu évoqué tout à l'heure mais
mathieu est intéressant de on n'a pas eu
de surprise effectivement pour vous
c'est aussi une surprise oui c'est mon
adolescence et janvier le disais tout à
l'heure c'est la personne la nomination
que personne n'a vu venir même 15 buts
avant qui skie ravin dans un univers où
les secrets ne reste jamais très
longtemps alors on l'a dit c'est un
universitaire reconnu claire chartier
l'a dit c'est un homme issu de la gauche
c est lui qui m'a des macros confie le
chantier qu'il a jugée prioritaire
pendant sa campagne de l'éducation
nationale
après avoir confié pendant cinq ans jean
michel blanquer une figure de la droite
qui était sur une ligne crème à ces
différentes et même sur une pratique du
pouvoir on attendra donc ce que fait ce
que fait pape ndiaye mais en tout cas
les gens qui ont travaillé avec lui
disent que c'est plutôt une approche
assez consensuel c'est quelqu'un qui
cherche le compromis alors que
jean-michel leblanc caire assumé d'une
certaine façon d'être client enfin c'est
un signal qui envoyait à tous ceux qui
dénoncent l'invisibilisation des
minorités en france et l'absence de role
models que de nommer le patron du musée
de l'immigration auteur d'un essai sur
la condition noire en france à la tête
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
bon coup politique goodness ça on verra
à l'usagé bien sûr mais en tout cas sa
seule nomination le disait aussi tout à
l'heure obtenu les effets exactement
recherché par emmanuel macron d'abord
ils sont là peut noter mais l'apaisement
chez les syndicats les syndicats de
l'éducation nationale étaient vent
debout contre le précédent locataire de
la rue de lorraine jean michel blanquer
là ça a été saluée on a salué sa
capacité d'empathie et d'écouté la
rupture qui était marqué avec son
prédécesseur certes d'autres syndicats
lui ont demandé d'ouvrir le dialogue au
plus vite sans tarder ouais c'est plutôt
un sans faute est de bonne augure dans
un corps enseignant qui était chauffée à
blanc après comment mesure que savons
qu'aux politiques que ça ça jette le
trouble chez un adversaire alors là on a
eu le système des dérapages en série
dans la droite extrême l'extrême droite
de la part à mon avis bien souvent de
nombreuses personnes qui n'avaient pas
lu ses livres parce que pap ndiaye a
sans doute des défauts il a une pensée
qui est qui et qui est propre à lui mais
ça n'est pas une figure du mourtis temps
comme certains voudraient le faire
croire il a d'ailleurs pris ses
distances avec ce mouvement en
considérant qu'il était parfois sectaire
caricatural qui n'adhérait pas à
exactement à tous à tous même s'ils
adhéraient la logique intersectionnelle
d'une certaine façon il n'adhérait pas à
tous à toutes les idéologies walk
simplement ils croient pas qu'ils aient
des waka absolument partout dans les
facultés ou dans l'enseignement ça a été
une occasion pour balma condor clivé à
la proche de ces élections législatives
et puis de l'autre côté ça brouiller
complètement les cartes à gauche et il
faut suivre les conversations et les
contorsions j'allais dire de la gauche
et de l'extrême gauche pouvait regarder
sur facebook sur twitter pour la mesurer
ou écouté par exemple ce qu'en disait
jean luc mélenchon c'était hier au grand
jury en l'écoutant j'ai salué
l'intellectuel
l'ancien directeur de musée de
l'immigration ou présidents changent pas
qu'elle était au gie son titre l'homme
engagé qui avait participé à la lutte
autrefois contre le front national mais
c'est surtout l'intellectuel que je
voulais saluer après bon et des droites
pourquoi comment je le sais parce que
les anciens gouvernements de droite
comme on appelle ça me rappelle le
désarroi qui avaient certes issa ceux
qui avaient saisi certains socialistes
évidemment en 2007 avec nicolas sarkozy
avait pratiqué l'ouverture en faisant
rentrer au gouvernement fadela amara
jean pierre jouyet martin hirsch est
évidemment bernard kouchner là tout d'un
coup les socialiser mais ils sont de
droite c'est qu'ils ont toujours été de
droite alors que quelques
il était de gauche savaient pas
forcément été correct c'est oui car la
triangulation a aussi ses limites faut
le savoir et sassou et certains de ses
participants des grands écarts qui
relève du claquage mais surtout le
principal risque pour pape ndiaye c'est
en fait son manque d'expérience
politique d'une certaine façon
souvenez-vous le dernier intellectuel
qui a été nommé alors lionel luc ferry
mais ça a été un tel succès que en
conflit avec les syndicats enseignants
il s'est fait nicolas sarkozy ministre
de l'intérieur qui avait fini par des
nouvelles affaires en discutant
directement avec les syndicats
enseignants alors que lui était ministre
de l'intérieur comme quoi faut faire
attention les ovni en politique ça passe
ou ça casse mais ça casse plus souvent
effectivement claire chartier c'est un
ministre la société civile mais c'est
compliqué 870000 en saignant crise des
vocations
majeur enfin en proposant un reportage
dans quelques jours sur sur ce thème des
syndicats qui était remonté mathieu
lundi qu'entre son prédécesseur sacré
défi quand même pour je dois dire que je
comprends le coût politique ce qui je
m'interroge est-ce que c'est pas un coup
précisément circonstanciel et un peu
trop circonstancielle parce que quand
même effectivement le chantier est assez
énorme et on peut malgré tout considérer
que c'est un avantage de connaître la
boutique alors vous allez me dire jean
michel blanquer connaissait parfaitement
la boutique et après avoir été porté aux
nues ça a donné ce que ça a donné mais
malgré tout premiers points dont je
pense que c'est quand même ça va quand
même être un handicap et puis deuxième
point surtout franchement on peut être à
peu près certain que les attaques ne
vont pas cesser donc comment finalement
mené à bien un chantier qui est aussi
déterminant d'après ce que dit emmanuel
macron qui est celui de l'éducation
lorsque vous placez à la tête du
ministère note ce ministère la clé
stratégique
quelqu'un qui va susciter autant de
dates attaques répétées j'avoue que
politiquement franchement je me suis
interrogé d'edel annonce parce que
vouloir être subversif pourquoi pas mais
aller aussi loin je suis pas certaine
que ça soit politiquement là aussi
judicieux
j'ai eu à peu près le réflexe inverse
mais sur la même surprise donc on va se
rejoindre c'est à mon sens ça peut être
aussi beaucoup de bruit pour rien pour
la simple et bonne raison que on est
dans l'entre-deux-tours emmanuel macron
nous dit qu'il aura deux chantiers
prioritaires l'école et la santé alors
très incarnée par le président et en
plus qui seront également les chantiers
de la nouvelle méthode de la codécision
donc donc dans ce chantier qui décide le
peuple et le président nous et le
ministre franchement j'ai le sentiment
que c'est le ministère où on allait
avoir le moins de pouvoir de décision
sur ce chantier là donc c'était aussi
pour moi le lieu de faire justement un
coup d'éclat en se disant de toute façon
les chantiers c'est moi qui vais gérer
envahir moi c'est un ami john opposition
il reste 13 alors voilà c'est là le
risque d'où le risque qu'un autre
exactement un ministre profondément
déconcentré profondément ancrée donc
d'où le risque notable à choisir
quelqu'un qui n'est pas politique mais
peut-être parce que ça n'est pas lui qui
décide et puis mathieu les hoquets
question de cohérence politique c'est à
dire que c'est peut-être caricatural
mais en tout cas entre jean michel
blanquer pap ndiaye on peut dire que
c'est pas exactement la même la même
conception de social ou gérald darmanin
la laïcité 2 e
du rôle de l'éducation nationale on l'a
en la matière enfin donc est ce qu'il ya
une cohérence politique dans dance est
dans le choix et dans cette nomination
on a eu lieu en même temps au sein du
gouvernement là on a le même temps
contre le gouvernement et nous avions
fait un point et mâcon de parce que
c'est pas complètement orthogonale quand
on lit précisément fait ce que peuvent
dire les uns ou les autres par mois les
positions étaient un peu caricaturée en
tout cas fait d'accord quand même pas
tout à fait la même philosophie la même
approche après ce que je trouve très
intéressant c'est que à aucun moment
quand on parle de son arrivée on parle
des moyens par les objectifs on parle de
la finalité on va beaucoup plus est sur
un débat de valeur et c'est là où ça va
être intéressant c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir un débat sur globalement quel type
de questions peut donner quel rapport on
peut avoir la réplique à le rapport on
peut avoir la laïcité qui sont parfois
même un peu à la marge du projet
éducatif en tout cas des programmes qui
sont proposées aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait
de toute façon c'est que quels que
soient les moyens qui sont donnés je
sais pas là pour j'ai pas là pour
dédouaner le gouvernement que dans cinq
ans à peu de choses près l'association
objectif sera sensiblement la même on
sait que pour réformer l'éducation
nationale que pour former des élèves que
pour faire en sorte que les processus
d'apprentissage et que l'objectif qui
est de faire en sorte que notamment le
la variable culturelle soit moins pesant
tu dans le principe de pouvoir accéder à
des niveaux de qualification que ça
supérieur sont terriblement loué en
général s'effectue sur plusieurs
générations donc dans ce contexte là on
va vraiment beaucoup plus jugé
l'éducation nationale au regard des
budgets notre pourra disposer de
l'attractivité en termes de métiers et
également des différents systèmes de
valeurs qui donneront le sentiment
d'avoir traversé l'ensemble de ces cinq
prochaines années je dis pas que c'est
pas important mais que à peu de choses
près c'est quand même les constructions
de long terme qui font les changements
dans l'acquisition des principaux savoir
de la part des jeunes généralistes
juillet puis à ton nom de jeu derniers
mois la de juger sur pièce quand même
assez sont sa première prise de parole
sur le perron du mistral d'éducation aux
côtés de jean michel blanquer a été
globalement assez raccord il a rappelé
son parcours c'est un produit de la
méritocratie républicaine il est pas
moins public uns que les autres son
premier déplacement était aujourd'hui à
conflans sainte honorine pour honorer la
mémoire de samuel pâtit alors est-ce
qu'il est obligé de donner des gages
pour montrer qu'il n'est pas la phrase
indigéniste qui va déconstruire à la
fois l'histoire de france notre système
scolaire comme le prétendent tous les
racistes qu'ils attaquent aujourd'hui on
en est là mais attendons de le juger sur
pièces en tout cas le voir ce qui
faisait écrire ses discours et ce qu'il
mènera comme politique et on terminera
dieu merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat pierre chartier je
rappelle le titre de cette enquête le
violet nous enquête sur un fléau social
livre publié aux édition de
l'observatoire